shinji commutes to work and he worries
about running out of fuel the amount of
fuel he uses follows a normal
distribution for each part of his
commute but the amount of fuel he uses
on the way home varies more the amounts
of fuel he uses for each part of the
commute are also independent of each
other
here are summary statistics for the
amount of fuel shinji uses for each part
of his commute so when he goes to work
he uses a mean of 10 liters of fuel with
a standard deviation of 1.5 liters and
on the way home he also has a mean of 10
liters but there is more variation there
is more spread he has a standard
deviation of 2 liters
suppose that shinji has 25 liters of
fuel in his tank and he intends to drive
to work and back home
what is the probability that shinji runs
out of fuel all right this is really
interesting we have the distribution for
the amount of fuel he uses to work and
to home and they say that these are
normal distributions they say that right
over here follows a normal distribution
but here we're talking about the total
amount of fuel he has to go to work and
to go home
so what we want to do is come up with a
total distribution home and back i guess
you could say we could call this work
plus
home
home and back if you have two random
variables that can be described by
normal distributions and you were to
define a new random variable as their
sum
the distribution of that new random
variable will still be a normal
distribution and its mean will be the
sum of the means of those other random
variables so the mean here i'll say the
mean
of work plus home
is going to be equal to 20 liters
he will use a mean of 20 liters in the
round trip
now for the standard deviation
from home
plus work you can't just add the
standard deviations going and coming
back but because the amount of fuel
going to work and the amount of fuel
coming home are independent random
variables because they are independent
of each other we can add the variances
and only because they are independent
can we add the variances so what you can
say is that the variance
of the combined trip
is equal to
the variance
of going to work
plus the variance of going home
so what's the variance of going to work
well 1.5 squared is so this will be 1.5
squared and what's the variance coming
home well this is going to be 2 squared
2 squared well this is 2.25
plus 4 which is equal to 6.25
so the variance
on the round trip
is equal to 6.25 if i were to take the
square root of that which is equal to
2.5
we can now describe the normal
distribution of the round trip and use
that to answer the question
so we have this normal distribution that
might look something like this
we know its mean is 20 liters
so this is 20 liters and we want to know
what is the probability that shinji runs
out of fuel well to run out of fuel he
would need to require more than 25
liters of fuel
so if 25 liters of fuel is right over
here
so this is
25 liters of fuel
the scenario where shinji runs out of
fuel is right over here this is where he
needs more than 25 liters he actually
has 25 liters in his tank so how do we
figure out that area right over there
well we could use a z table we could say
how many standard deviations above the
mean is 25 liters
well it is 5 liters above the mean so
let me write this down so the z here
the z is equal to
minus the mean minus 20 divided by the
standard deviation for i guess you could
say this combined normal distribution
this is two standard deviations above
the mean or a z-score of plus 2.
so if we look at a z-table and we look
exactly two standard deviations above
the mean
that will give us this area the
cumulative area below
two standard deviations above the mean
and then if we subtract that from 1 we
will get the area that we care about
so let's get our z table out
we care about a z score of exactly 2 so
2.00
is right over here 0.9772
so that tells us that this area right
over here is 0.9772
and so that blue area the probability
that xinji runs out of fuel is going to
be 1 minus
0.9772
and what is that going to be equal to
let's see this is going to be equal to
0.0228
[Music]
did i do that right i think i did that
right
yes 0.022
eight is the probability that shinji
runs out of fuel if you want to think of
it as a percent two point two eight
percent chance that he runs out of fuel